[Musica]
Buonasera tranquilli il mio intervento
Durerà solo 45 minuti
Io sono Federica Cacciola faccio
l'attrice sono diventata conosciuta
qualche tempo fa qualche anno fa
attraverso il personaggio di Martina
dell'ombra un personaggio che molti
hanno preso per vero ma è un personaggio
di finzione che nella realtà non esiste
come Paperino Babbo Natale Di Maio
da quando faccio questo lavoro la cosa
che ho sentito dire più spesso che mi
hanno detto più spesso e che le donne
non fanno ridere Le donne non dovrebbero
fare satira perché la vera donna
dovrebbe essere calda accogliente
rassicurante una stufa a gas
non me la stufa a gas non piacciono e
quindi continua a fare quello che faccio
io vivo a Milano da 18 anni
E un'altra cosa che mi sento dire molto
spesso quando qualcuno mi incontra per
strada è
Ma te non sei di Milano io dico no
infatti io non sono di Milano Eh si vede
che sei di Roma
dicono in realtà non sono di Roma Io
sono siciliana e a quel punto mi
guardano un po' stupiti e dicono non si
direbbe proprio
perché
perché non si direbbe che cosa si
aspettano da me che io vada in giro con
la lupara a ballare una tarantella
mentre dico Minchia che freddo cosa che
fra l'altro faccio molto spesso però mi
dispiace a me dispiace non averlo
scritto in faccia di dove sono Perché io
qui ci sono nata e ci sono anche
cresciuta esattamente a Sant'Alessio
Siculo un paesino a 14 km da Taormina di
mille abitanti e poi mi sono trasferita
qui a Messina dove ho fatto tutti gli
anni del liceo 120 più o meno mi
confermate Almeno a me sono sembrati
così lunghissimi infiniti come le
declinazioni e poi a 18 anni mi sono
trasferita a Milano
e mi sono sempre chiesta Ma perché le
persone
da qui se ne vanno certo Ora potremmo
citare tantissimi studi pubblicazioni
che spiegano i motivi socio culturali
economici e politici del Perché molti
ragazzi del Sud se ne vanno in altri
posti a studiare e poi ci rimangono ma
non voglio parlare di questo io voglio
proprio capire in generale perché ad un
certo punto alcune persone se ne vanno
dai posti dove sono nate e cresciute
ovviamente escludendo le persone che
scappano da luoghi di guerra o da
situazioni di estrema povertà disastri
politici perché voglio dire Messina non
è un gioiello però ancora non c'è una
guerra civile
per ora quanto
non si sa mai
Però una cosa che succede molto spesso
certo uno può dire bello studio
certo uno si sposta magari per lavoro
certo per avere opportunità migliori
Ma è davvero solo questo
Secondo me no Secondo me c'è una
piccolissima parte che dipende dal fatto
che dove nasci e dove cresci lì ci sono
tutti i tuoi traumi tutti insieme
concentrati tipo concentrato di pomodoro
ed è così anche per me qui ci sono tutti
i miei traumi
E qui la strada che mi ha vista cadere
di faccia spaccandomi il mento quando
stavo andando al primo appuntamento con
il ragazzo che mi piaceva Che figura di
merda
esattamente la Tommaso Cannizzaro
ed è sempre qui la focacceria dove un
giorno stavo prendendo per pranzo la
focaccia e una signora mi ha guardato il
mio dettato tutta questa focaccia ti
mangi per questo hai preso qualche
chiletto
ed è sempre qui nel bagno della mia casa
sulla 24 maggio che quello stesso
pomeriggio dopo aver mangiato quella
focaccia io mi sono ficcata due dita in
gola e l'ho vomitata tutta fino
all'ultimo pezzo perché una sconosciuta
aveva fatto un commento sul mio corpo
è sempre qui nelle aule del liceo
classico maurolico che ho iniziato ad
avere le mie prime crisi di panico
casualmente sempre prima delle
interrogazioni di matematica
ed è sempre nei corridoi di quello
stesso liceo che un giorno due compagni
di scuola passandomi accanto mi hanno
sussurrato buttana
un'emozione incredibile
era la prima volta che qualcuno mi
diceva qualcosa del genere e non sarebbe
stata certo l'ultima perché non avrei
mai potuto immaginare che anni dopo
quando avrei iniziato a mettere dei
video su internet quella cosa in un
altro modo me l'avrebbero detta tutti i
giorni qualunque cosa dicessi Buongiorno
muori Grazie signora Buona
domenica anche a lei
la cosa bella è che su internet te
lo dicono qualunque cosa tu faccia
quelli che non capiscono che faccio
satira mi dicono se una fascista brutta
quelli che capiscono che faccio
satira mi dicono se una comunista brutta
quelli che non capiscono che
faccio l'attrice mi dicono trovati un
lavoro brutta quelli che capiscono
che faccio l'attrice mi dicono Cambia
lavoro brutta se metto una foto
scollata Mi dicono mostri sempre le
tette brutta se metto una foto
accollata mi dicono ma almeno mostra le
tette brutta brutta sul web
Come il nero sta bene con tutto che poi
fosse solo Ma perché devono sempre
aggiungere anche brutta
nessuno di questi insulti mi ha mai
realmente offesa nessuno di questi
mi ha mai davvero ferita ma quel buttana
sussurrato nei corridoi del maurolico sì
Forse perché limitazione buttana è
la parola originale non lo so
Fatto sta che è così
è vero che qui non ci sono soltanto i
traumi Qui ci sono anche alcune delle
esperienze più belle che ho avuto nella
vita ci sono alcuni ricordi bellissimi
come quando saltavo scuola e andavo a
fare colazione del re era sì mamma l'ho
fatto
oppure le prime giornate d'estate al
Pilone oppure quando mi andavo ad
imboscare a piazzetta preservativo sulla
litoranea
Sì Papà ho fatto anche quello i miei
genitori si sono pentiti di essere
venuti qui stasera
ci sono un sacco di ricordi importanti
però ci ricordiamo sempre di più i
traumi
ed è così Che trauma dopo trauma io mi
ero convinta di avere un buco per carità
di buchini ottanti Per fortuna come
tutti ma di averne uno in particolare
uno un po' strano di avere un buco qua
al centro del petto dove gli altri hanno
l'amore per la vita Io pensavo di avere
un buco profondissimo e mi ero
rassegnata l'idea di doverci convivere
per sempre con questo buco di farci di
doverci quasi fare amicizia Come va oggi
È così che parlo un buco al centro del
petto Secondo me
certo può anche essere comodo avere un
buco al centro del petto ci metti quello
che vuoi amori finiti relazioni che
vanno male fallimenti gli avanzi della
cena
e poi un giorno quando ero in un posto
veramente molto lontano in un paese
straniero dove si parlava una lingua
molto diversa dalla mia e non mi
riferisco al calabrese
ero su una spiaggia
che mi ha ricordato di colpo la spiaggia
di casa mia e il mare che avevo davanti
mi ha ricordato di colpo il mare di casa
mia e l'aria calda mi ha ricordato
l'aria calda di casa mia nelle giornate
in cui c'è Scirocco
ed è lì quando ero lontanissima da casa
mia che ho pensato profondamente a casa
mia
a quel punto è successo una cosa strana
perché qua al centro del petto dove io
sentivo quel vuoto ho iniziato a sentire
qualcosa di diverso come una luce e ho
guardato e ho trovato quella che mi è
sembrata essere una palla luminosa so
che raccontato così sembra Iron Man però
non ho altre parole per descriverlo ho
guardato e c'era proprio questa luce e
da lì ho capito
che la ferita all'interno della quale ci
sono tutti i traumi e luminosa nel senso
che emette luce propria
e tutte le scintille che ho fatto nella
vita tutte le cose che ho realizzato con
quella luce sono nata proprio da lì
proprio da quella ferita proprio da quei
traumi
e credo che sia per questo che certe
persone hanno bisogno di allontanarsi
dai posti dove nascono e crescono perché
a volte quando stai troppo vicino alle
cose non hai modo di vederle bene e ha
bisogno di un po' di distanza di un po'
di lontananza per renderti conto di chi
sei
ed è per questo che alcune persone hanno
bisogno di andarsene per avere un posto
dove tornare e dire Qui c'è la mia casa
per avere un posto dove tornare e dire
Qui c'è la mia luce
Grazie